[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa del espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
con un llamado a la unión joe biden juró
como presidente de eeuu prometió ser el
mandatario de todos los ciudadanos
incluso de quienes no están de acuerdo
con él y donald trump pasa a la historia
como el primer presidente de la unión
americana en ser sometido a dos juicios
políticos con miras a su destitución en
el senado revisamos sus cuatro años en
el poder y por primera vez en un siglo
el carnaval de río de janeiro fue
cancelado el evento ya había sido
aplazado desde su fecha original en
febrero hasta julio debido a la pandemia
del cob y 19 pero algunas escuelas de
samba se mantendrán activas le contamos
con nuestras corresponsales
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal con la mano derecha
sobre la biblia que ha estado en su
familia por más de 127 años y ante el
presidente de la corte suprema de
justicia john roberts
joe biden se convirtió en el presidente
número 46 de la unión americana tras
unas semanas convulsas por el asalto al
capitolio por parte de seguidores de
donald trump bailén aseguró que la
democracia se impuso y prometió gobernar
incluso para quienes no están de acuerdo
con su llegada a la oficina oval
haciendo alusión a los seguidores del
ahora ex presidente que creen en sus
infundadas denuncias de fraude en su
primer día en la casa blanca- bailén nos
dejó la cifra de la semana 17 este es el
número de órdenes ejecutivas que firmó
sólo unas horas después de su
investidura entre ellas congeló la
construcción del muro fronterizo puso
fin al veto al ingreso al país de
ciudadanos de países de mayoría
musulmana ordenó el reingreso de eeuu al
acuerdo de parís contra el cambio
climático suspendió la salida de la
organización mundial de la salud con
el proyecto del oleoducto kingston
además de otra serie de medidas contra
el kobe 19 como el uso obligatorio de la
mascarilla en instalaciones federales
las decisiones revierten las adoptadas
por donald trump en cuatro años en el
poder
revisemos los momentos más destacados de
la inédita presidencia del magnate
neoyorquino en el informe de andrés 12
una transición marcada por risas y
cordialidad
una posesión presidencial en la que se
anunciaban grandes virajes
only américa first es tan pronto como el
presidente 45 de eeuu tomó el mando una
retórica de confrontación llegó a la
casa blanca- nation wars star nation
el primero de marzo de 2017 llegaba una
gran cita para el nuevo presidente su
primer discurso del estado de la unión
lucha per
también marking ratings
snabi quien en el primero de junio trump
anuncia un nuevo revés para el
multilateralismo
viena 16 well well
from the players
wilmer y cork
las relaciones del medio oriente también
se vieron afectadas por un polémico
anuncio de trump style
hasta el 8 de mayo de 2018
trump cumple una de sus promesas de
campaña united states clouet road from
the green nuclear
en abril de 2019 una victoria para trump
el informe del fiscal miller no concluye
que hubo colusión en la llamada trama
rusa la presunta injerencia de rusia en
las elecciones no colusión nos escuche
en junio una de las imágenes más
notables de su mandato trump se
convierte en el primer presidente de
eeuu en pisar corea del norte y en
diciembre el presidente es acusado por
la cámara de representantes de abuso de
poder y obstrucción de la labor del
congreso 2020 sería un año agridulce
para trump el 16 de enero el senado
inicia el proceso de destitución
impeachment fútbol doméstico de febrero
el presidente es absuelto de titus
angers en austin not getting start
el resto de 2020 estaría dominado por la
pandemia que empezó negando
ep
del año 2020 también estuvo marcado por
manifestaciones contra abusos policiales
en especial contra afroamericanos en
mayo trump enfrenta una serie de
protestas por la muerte del
afroamericano georges floyd asfixiado
por un oficial de policía blanco
la imagen del presidente visitando una
iglesia tras desalojar a los
manifestantes cerca a la casa blanca
generaría indignación tras un convulso
año llega el 3 de noviembre día de unas
elecciones presidenciales atípicas
marcadas por una masiva participación
anticipada y por correo lo que
retrasaría los resultados finales
[Aplausos]
el 4 de noviembre de trump se niegan a
reconocer su derrota y alega sin ninguna
prueba fraude
tres días después maiden es declarado
ganador en pensilvania y de esta manera
se convertiría en presidente electo de
eeuu
trump y sus partidarios presentan
múltiples demandas contra el resultado
todas son rechazadas por las cortes por
no aportar pruebas el 6 de enero en un
último intento desesperado tram convoca
a una manifestación de sus partidarios y
en un discurso incendiario los llama a
marchar al capitolio mientras los
congresistas votan la certificación del
presidente electo joe biden
wi fi y wi fi en el bidón firewall y en
contra y en limón
[Música]
en un hecho sin precedentes centenares
de trompistas fanáticos muchos de ellos
de grupos de extrema derecha asaltan el
capitolio el vice presidente mike pence
y los legisladores se ven obligados a
refugiarse cinco personas entre ellas un
policía mueren
tras estos hechos en el congreso los
demócratas aprueban iniciar un
impeachment por incitación a la
insurrección
trump se niega a asistir a la posesión
del show by the end realizada en medio
de extraordinarias medidas de seguridad
por temor a nueva violencia
y veamos la imagen de la semana bernie
sanders y sus guantes que se robaron el
show de la ceremonia de la juramentación
de joe biden
el senador por vermont fue fotografiado
entre las escaleras del capitolio con su
mascarilla en las piernas cruzadas un
voluminoso abrigo y sus guantes para
protegerse de las bajas temperaturas de
washington dice
la imagen empezó a circular en redes
sociales entre obras de arte y películas
desde sanders en la luna hasta sentado
con forrest gump nos deja decenas de
gracias hicimos memes los guantes que
fueron un regalo de una ama de casa de
vermont se agotaron
y vamos al triángulo del norte del
continente para revisar otras noticias
de las américas esta semana las fuerzas
de seguridad de guatemala disolvieron a
la fuerza a la caravana de migrantes
centroamericanos que pretendía llegar a
eeuu méxico por su parte desplegó a la
guardia nacional en su frontera sur los
migrantes esperaban llegar a la unión
americana en búsqueda de un nuevo
destino con joe bait algunos siguen
varados esperando el paso mientras que
otros emprendieron su regreso a honduras
y en este país centroamericano el
parlamento aprobó un decreto que
penaliza el aborto en cualquier
circunstancia incluso en casos de
violación o incesto malformación del
feto o cuando la vida de la mujer está
en peligro en honduras uno de cada
cuatro partos es de una menor de 19 años
según la onu
con esta decisión honduras se une al
grupo de 6 países de la región que
prohíbe el aborto junto a el salvador
nicaragua república dominicana haití y
surinam
el ex secretario de defensa de méxico
salvador cienfuegos quien fue arrestado
por tráfico de drogas y lavado de dinero
en eeuu en octubre y que luego fue
trasladado sorpresivamente a méxico y
recientemente exonerado por la
procuraduría de ese país sigue en la
nómina del gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador como accesorios ante los
cuestionamientos al respecto el
presidente mexicano dijo que la dea
fabricó el caso en su contra
y vamos a brasil porque las autoridades
de río de janeiro cancelaron el carnaval
2021 previsto para el mes de julio
debido a la pandemia del cob y 19 si
vienen la vacunación ya empezó en el
gigante sudamericano las autoridades
reconocieron que supone un reto preparar
el evento en tan poco tiempo por primera
vez en un siglo la ciudad del carnaval
se quedará sin festejos pero la escuela
del samba mangueira puede transferir su
sabiduría ancestral a un público
reducido gracias a una iniciativa del
museo de arte moderno de río que
organiza durante los meses de verano
cursos de percusión y danza con los
profesionales de esta agremiación
cultural veamos el informe de nuestras
corresponsales
en un año normal la escuela de samba
mangueira estaría repleta y cientos de
personas estarían ensayando para el
desfile en el sambódromo
el coronavirus acabo con estas
aglomeraciones festivas la serie de la
famosa mangueira está desierta
solo los pasos del maestro weasley
interrumpen un silencio sepulcral
cuando veo este local así siento mucha
tristeza en esta época ya deberíamos
estar apresurándonos porque el carnaval
cae en febrero ya estaríamos preparando
los disfraces en la recta final con los
arreglos de la batería
hoy es un día diferente para weasley por
primera vez impartirá un taller de
percusión en el museo de arte moderno de
río los temores salen de la favela
mangueira rumbo al templo de la cultura
carioca
vamos a enseñar a los alumnos toda la
historia de la batería de la manguera
cómo surgió y por qué tiene un ritmo
diferente de todas las otras escuelas de
samba
no siempre la favela fue bienvenida en
este museo hace medio siglo los artistas
de la manguera fueron invitados a
exhibirse durante una exposición pero
cuando llegaron la dirección del museo
no los dejó entrar
el museo recupera la obra del artista
helio oiticica que en los años 60
desfiló como bailarín en esta escuela de
samba la decisión de invitar a los
artistas negros de la favela otrora
discriminados revela la transformación
paulatina de la sociedad brasileña
existe una subalternidad del
conocimiento de la samba y en realidad
de toda la cultura popular no sólo en
brasil sino en el mundo entero
la relación intelectual popular es vista
como algo menor y nosotros aquí pensamos
que esto no tiene que ser practicado más
de prácticas
weasley se emociona cuando recuerda su
infancia la música le mantuvo lejos del
crimen que mató a muchos de sus amigos
a la manguera el carnaval en sí los
instrumentos de la escuela de samba me
llevaron por un camino totalmente
diferente para que llegase hasta aquí
para mí es importante estar dentro de un
museo de arte moderno pasando un poco de
mi experiencia con la batería de la
manguera esto me deja muy feliz
bien
antes de la pandemia o weasley recorrió
el mundo como un verdadero embajador de
la samba además de su simbolismo este
taller también ayuda a un gremio que sin
carnaval y sin eventos se ha quedado sin
sustento económico
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américas y pueden síganme en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho el coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]
me muerdo los labios